hello welcome to sunday morning science
john perry here
my guest today is dr garrett mariam
he is a uh professor
of philosophy he works for california
state university sacramento and
he has a youtube channel which is how i
originally found him
syphilis syphilis wow
sisyphus redeemed
and that he has been teaching
the science of of the philosophy of
science
there on youtube and he's got videos
from going
years and years back and that's really
he really helped me clarify my thinking
about science when i first started
teaching science
on the internet so uh it's it's a it's a
real pleasure to have him on here
garrett hello hi john thanks for having
me on
yeah yeah sorry for slaughtering your
youtube
no when i first started my youtube
channel i i was having a back and forth
with uh a catholic uh uh philosopher and
he once jokingly called me
syphilis re-damned and so i always
thought that was kind of a clever uh
clever
turn of phrase yeah well well tell us
about that
that that name because that's that's uh
what's the french guy's name
um albert camus albert camus yeah so
so yeah yeah yeah tell us about that so
kemu has this famous essay
of the myth of sisyphus in which he
explores and sort of deconstructs
the the ancient greek myth of this this
king sisyphus who gets condemned uh to
push a rock up a hill for eternity
and as soon as the rock gets the top of
hill it rolls down again he has to push
it back up again
right uh so you know in the myth the
idea is that uh
uh the the worst torment is the idea
that everything that you do everything
that you work on
will be undone eventually by time so no
matter how much you care about something
on how to invest in you know your book
or your artwork or your even your family
sooner or later
time's going to erase it all so the
question becomes this deep
existentialist riddle of how can we find
meaning in life
knowing that everything we do is
permanent and transient
um and and camus argues that uh this is
representative of of life as human
beings and we have to find ways
to make our lives meaningful uh in the
face of our finitude
um and so when i was searching for a
youtube channel i happened to be
reading that essay at the time uh and
you know i i was sort of toying around
the idea of redemption what it means to
be redeemed what it means to be damned
and i
i i had liked the way camus articulated
uh a kind of redemption a non sort of
non-christian non-theistic vision
of what it means to redeem oneself in
the face of our own mortality so
grab it embracing the absurdity huh
uh what
what got you into to philosophy of
science
uh well i'm one of those incredibly
lucky people who figured out
fairly early on in my life exactly what
i wanted to do um
i came into college as a philosophy
major which actually is kind of rare
most people
come in as something else take uh take a
philosophy class just to try it out and
then they fall in love with it and
become majors but
uh you know in high school i was reading
you know emmanuel kant and i
didn't understand much of it but i knew
i liked it um and so i came in as a
freshman philosophy major my very first
day of college uh
intro philosophy class with professor
jeffrey king university california davis
and literally after the first lecture
it's like yeah i can do this this is
what i want to do
um from that moment on i've just been uh
focused on it and one of the things that
i love about philosophy in general
is that it allows you to have your
fingers in so many different pies you
know you're
saying philosophy you can study the
nature of law
religion ethics and morality art you can
study history
uh you know you can study enforce
science uh
so if you have an intro a broad uh array
of
intellectual interests as i do uh
philosophy allows you to get a little
bit of everything
um which you know sometimes that can be
a problem because you may spread
yourself too thin
uh but i'm not looking to revolutionize
the world in any particular field i just
want to have an appreciation for what's
going on in all these different
areas uh so uh you know there's
philosophy of science it
gets to what i find to be allows you to
get the most interesting interesting
things out of science
without having to necessarily master uh
you know calculus or anything like that
uh which
is not to say anything ill of studying
calculus obviously it's a very important
thing to study
um but uh i think you can have
the intellectual stimulation without
having to have the uh incredibly highly
specialized mastery of any particular
subfield
uh in order to to to get the fun out of
it yeah yeah
i i i for anyone who has not seen
his youtube videos please go check some
of those out there
a lot of them are longer and they're
kind of lecture style and i love it for
like working out or you know just
i do a lot of drawing i do i'm an
animator so i do a lot of i spend a lot
of time drawing and that's that's
usually when i listen to your stuff is
when i'm
when i'm doing some big illustration
project and it's
it's kind of perfect for me because i
drawing actually gets me in the mode to
really think deeply about these sorts of
things
and uh it's it's it's been a real
pleasure to
go through your stuff uh
i have i have one question we've got a
list of questions here that i had sent
you but i actually have one
off the cuff that i was thinking about
um
this morning and obviously as
a philosopher of science you're very
interested in science you spent a lot of
time studying the history which is very
obvious you're
you're very well versed on that
what are your feelings do you think that
the science scientific project
overall is going to be uh good for
humanity or do you think that
it's just allowing us to burn the candle
at both ends we've invented so much
we've changed our species so much we've
changed how we live on this planet so
much
what what do you think about that um
well uh again hearkening back somewhat
to the myth of sisyphus
i think it's worth noting that our time
on this planet is limited
as individuals and as a species one way
or another
sooner or later we will no longer exist
here
so one picture is yeah we we
slow down you know uh you could you
could put it at the doorstep of science
if you want or you could put at the
doorstep of capitalism or industrialism
or something like that
um but if you know if you keep it simple
we can just say we can stop
doing what we've been doing heretofore
uh and sort of surrender
the benefits that we've we've had um
stay you know benighted stay ignorant
about the world
but keep the world around keep it so so
our ancestors can live on for for
millennia longer
um alternatively we can as you say burn
the candle at both ends
uh we may consume all our natural
resources and we may die out sooner
uh or we may be able to reach beyond
this planet uh to to
make it to mars or maybe even someplace
else uh and
and spread our existence further so
there's kind of a game theoretic model
you could look at here uh uh
do we do we wanted uh to shoot the moon
in the possibly in the literal sense
shoot the moon
um uh and and try for uh both
uh uh elongated human existence
throughout the the solar system if not
the universe
um or do we wanna play it safe and just
stay on the planet and try to preserve
the the planet that we have
and i think there's an interesting
debate to be had you know in
environmental ethics about that
uh but personally for uh for for my part
you know i i think we're
we're here uh to try to make the most of
it to try to understand what we can
understand
um uh you know it's to to for fear of
appear
appearing appealing to a abused concept
it's kind of in our nature as human
beings
to be curious and to understand things
uh and as such i don't really think
there's any other way around it we're
gonna
try to figure it out we're gonna try to
solve problems and and
one of the consequences of that is that
we are going to consume resources
right um and that's not to be glib about
the the costs of consuming those
resources
but uh you know when you look at the big
picture this is who we are we're
explorers and we're not going to stop
so yeah that is that is interesting i've
i've uh i mean the reason that i love
science the reason i teach science is
just because of the the personal
insights it's been able to give me that
i've found so valuable
but uh it's it is quite shocking when
when you realize that
this project is going and no one can
stop it you know i mean
wherever it leads it's going to keep
going it's going to keep going until
until we get to wherever that is um
it just it it seems like once we
invented this culturally invented this
thing called science
it just it took off and it's yeah we're
we're along for the ride
it's it's quite interesting so
i'd like to talk about you know
how is modern science different from
other projects aiming to describe
aspects of how reality works like
what is the big difference between
science and
well basically any you know in the past
you had
religion religious ideas dominated you
had um
all sorts of different cultural ideas
that would dominate authoritative
figures who would tell people how the
world worked and so on
how is it that science is different from
that
well there's lots of different answers
to that question as you can imagine of
course uh that people have proposed over
the years
um i i the the first uh
uh video or the first substantive video
in my philosophy of science series i i
unpacked peter godfrey smith's answer to
this
uh and he says there's three three major
candidates that you can break down
uh the first is empiricism uh you know
broadly defined simply as
uh trying to to make sure that our
beliefs
uh coincide with our experiences of the
world first and foremost
so observation based yeah observation
based uh the second
is mathematization uh the the attempt to
use the tools of mathematics
to model uh the world in the most
accurate way possible
and the third is the social structure of
science uh uh using things
like scientific societies uh uh
scientific publications peer review and
so forth
uh to set up a kind of a process in
which we we backstop each other and
check each other's work and so forth
uh to make sure that any mistakes we
made get called out
uh and self-corrected um and
you know while these different views
have different champions in
a variety of ways it seems pretty clear
i think to most people
most of my students when i cover this uh
that the correct answer is that some
combination of these three things
uh that's now we might want to
prioritize one
over the other in this particular field
or that particular field or something
like that
but broadly speaking uh science requires
all three of these things it requires
empirical information it requires
mathematical modeling and it requires a
social structure
uh that allows us to distribute the
layer epistemic labor in such
a way that we do it effectively and
efficiently at least in in the long run
yeah so so you see science as a social
project so
i guess uh well maybe this is just
too far off but you couldn't do science
alone on an island
yeah no i i i remember when i was an
undergraduate i actually read an essay
by michael crichton the novelist
right um and it was right around the
time right
yeah yeah jurassic park yeah uh and he
wrote another book called state of fear
which i have not read uh but it was sort
of his book in which he was trying to
sort of
say that uh the global warming was a
hoax uh and that the government was
using it to
to gin up fear and stuff like that um
and it kind of disappointed me because
um in general i'm a fan of michael
crichton i like his work uh
and uh i think it's it is unambiguously
clear today as it was back then
that global warming is not a hoax um uh
so even though i didn't read that novel
i did read the essay that he published
alongside it in which he was sort of
trying to philosophically justify what
he was saying
and one of the things he brought up is a
common talking point uh that
many climate change uh skeptics and
deniers will bring up
uh which is the idea that science isn't
determined by consensus you know
you can have one person and the
canonical person here uh is
is galileo right now according to the
typical story
galileo uh uh bucked the scientific
trends of his day the entire scientific
community
was saying that the earth is at the
center of everything uh and galileo had
was the one man who had the courage to
stand up and say no that's not true
um and he was uh persecuted by the
church of course
um but ultimately he ended up being
vindicated and it's a romantic story
right i think it really appeals to this
american
in particular to americans this idea of
the rugged individualist scientist who
goes out there
and overturns the consensus and
challenges the group think and stuff
like that
um it's the kind of thing i think that
appeals to a lot of people about science
and there's something heroic
about it but it's just historically
inaccurate
that's just not the way galileo's story
worked it's not the way any story worked
galileo had a lot of people at his back
uh working with him most notably of
course a hundred years before him was
copernicus
uh and in that that's in the century
between copernicus and galileo
there was just a gradual consensus
moving in that direction
there were legitimate scientific reasons
for thinking that copernicus and galileo
were wrong so there was a legitimate
scientific debate it wasn't just
religion versus
science yeah um but but uh but galileo
was not some lone hero
he had a social structure at his back
which helped him and supported him
uh both a political structure he was
actually protected by a local prince for
quite some time was part of the reason
why
what allowed him to make these bold
claims uh but even
apart from the politics there was a
scientific establishment that was double
checking his work
uh and and and it was showing that the
the predictions he was making
panned out better than the old polymatic
system and so forth
so uh there have actually been cases of
literal scientists
on islands doing scientific work and
their names go down in history but
they're never working alone they always
have people working with them
i mean even if it's not necessarily even
if they're alone in their own
lab sooner or later someone else has to
come along and double check their work
and make sure they did they didn't they
didn't falsify their own
their research in some way or uh or or
or screw something up uh
so yeah you could you can have someone
do part of science all by themselves
you know there are parts of it that can
be individualistic
but the collective enterprise of science
by its very nature requires a social set
up to be done
yeah yeah when would you say that
modern science really finally
crystallized
in a way that we will really recognize
it today and
have other cultures had something this
had something similar in the past that
made it maybe went extinct and then
reemerged here yeah i'm tempted to give
the glib answer that it hasn't yet um
yeah but that's that's just because
uh you know i mean you never know how
history is going to look back at this
period of time right you know
assuming the human race survives 100 200
300 years from now looking back at this
time period are they going to look at
what we call science
and say that there's something sort of
clearly continuous between this
and you know stretching forward back as
galileo and then up until their current
day
yeah uh and i imagine obviously i could
be wrong but i imagine they're going to
see precisely what we see when we look
back over the last 300 400 years or so
um uh and it's a gradual you know
evolution of of practices uh uh
of values of of of organizations
um that constantly continue with the
biological metaphor mutates
um and while there's obviously something
consistent
connecting these time periods um it's
it's really hard to pin down precisely
the essence
of science uh um and i for when i'm
comfortable with that i don't think
that it's necessary for scientists or
philosophers to say that this is the
thing that makes science science
uh it can be a cluster property uh that
changes and evolves
um and that's part of what makes it
exciting right i mean what part about
what's fun
about imagining the future you know when
i'm on my deathbed
uh is not just the specific scientific
conclusions that we've come to and how
they change
but how scientific methodology changes
and how the nature of
what we think about as science changes
it's changed a lot in the last 100 years
and is every reason to think it's going
to change in the next 100 years too
yeah i i when i read about the history
of science if i try and look up that
specifically
i get a lot of um kind of european
uh stories and i
i'm not sure how much of of you know
asian and indian culture
you've been able to study in your and
your work but i
i mean when you look at these
civilizations
they're absolutely amazing and it seems
to me that there must be must have been
something
similar to science back then i i've
actually read quite a bit of of
islamic uh like alchemy and stuff
and you see very very clear
uh slivers of what we have today
uh mixed with religion and mythology and
all sorts of things but it's
it seems like this something like this
has existed in multiple different
cultures and seems to have come up
independently
yeah i'm glad you bring this up because
uh uh one of the
a couple of videos in my series is on
the history of science and one of things
that i
sincerely regret about that series and
have been meaning to go back and correct
for some time now
is how eurocentric my own videos and my
short videos on the history of uh
of science are um part of that just
reflects my own educational background
it has focused principally on
european and american history of science
um but uh you are absolutely right that
uh
there's been tremendous advances in in
science uh over history uh in islamic
cultures and far eastern cultures
uh uh in african cultures um and
they don't get enough focus and credit
from scholars
such as myself and other scholars
working in the history of science
um so yeah i've been i've been slowly
broadening my own horizons on that um
and wanting to to to to do a follow-up
video uh talking about
uh non-european history of science um
and you mentioned alchemy which i'm also
glad about because i think that that's
uh sometimes people will treat alchemy
as though it's a
pseudoscience or it's non-scientific in
some way and i think that's actually a
mistake
um the it you get these stories about
alchemy which are just
uh uh sort of these uh simplistic
versions that make it seem pseudo
scientific oh you can transmute lead
into gold for example something everyone
seems to know
uh but there was so so much more to it
than that um
and in many ways it has a lot of the
things that we consider to be
science uh there's empirical methods uh
there there's there's rigorous testing
um my understanding it seems to be the
principal difference between alchemy as
we understand it today in chemistry
actually has
far less to do with the scientific
methods themselves and more to do with
the social structure alchemy
was by its very nature occultish uh yeah
there's very very protective
and they they didn't share work with
each other they didn't uh backstop
each other um and they went to
deliberate efforts to keep their things
secretive and in a lot of ways it
actually kind of resembles
what a lot of corporations are doing
nowadays with their own sort of science
where they want to keep their own trade
secrets
um uh and so in some interesting ways
we're almost sort of resuscitating uh
some of the alchemical
uh models of science uh in in corporate
scientific research these days and it's
it's
it's an interesting historical
perspective to to try to shed some light
on what we're doing today
yeah if you go into a chemistry lab
i would say probably 40 of the
the glassware they're using was invented
by alchemists so
the i mean that that stuff comes from
islamic alchemy
all the all the things for distillation
and and and uh
yeah pulling pulling uh substances apart
so yeah it's it's it's been it's been
interesting for me going back and and
reading some of this stuff i had a
i recently did an animation for stated
clearly on
the what is an atom and i had to go
i ended up going on this deep dive
through just
all these different people who were
talking about the idea of the atom there
was a
an indian philosopher who had come up
with it long before
uh democritus or had been writing about
it long before i'm sure people have come
up with this
time and time again and independently
but
you know we use the word adam because
that comes from democritus and that
was then uh
rediscovered by europeans who were who
were studying chemistry
but that that concept just it's
it pops up all over the place so it's
there's this issue of who do you give
credit to and
uh you know all sorts of issues here
with
with uh with the history of science that
that are really complicated
and now that we have the internet and
youtube i i have people sending me
emails like oh you should have
you should have talked about this guy
and and this guy from from my culture
and you know it's it's interesting to
see this uh
this happening i lived in brazil brazil
for a while and they claimed that they
invented the airplane before the wright
brothers
and i hadn't heard that so it's um
yeah just just the
studying history is very
trying to piece together the history of
science is really difficult because we
really have to
we we pick and choose what we're
familiar with and what we're um
you know what's translated into the
languages that we speak so
it's it's everything's a little bit
skewed when you're when you're doing
historical research
it's one of the strange things about the
sociology of science is that
a lot of people seem to be highly
motivated by the idea of credit
right you know they want to be the
scientist who makes a lasting impact on
their field you know they want to win
the nobel prize
uh for example um and you know not all
scientists care about that obviously
sometimes scientists just care about the
work
and care about learning they don't care
about getting their name in in the
history books anything like that but
a lot of scientists do uh and on the one
hand
that provides a powerful incentive for a
lot of people to work very hard and do
really good science
yeah but on the other hand it also can
kind of create this
weird sort of jockeying uh for priority
uh where you know this scientist says i
came up with this idea first no i came
up with it first
you know i have no idea if democritus or
this this uh this was it an indian
philosophy said or indian thinker
who came up with that first would would
have cared whether or not they got the
priority um but it wouldn't surprise me
if they did
um and in some ways you know at least
when that when they're so long dead it
kind of you know
as a historian you sort of start to
wonder what the value of the project is
of trying to figure out who came up with
it first
yeah because it was very clearly an
armchair idea right it's one of those
ideas that you know it's you're you're
going to stumble onto it sooner or later
even if no one teaches you about it
right uh it's the second you start
thinking about physical stuff and you
realize you can tear a piece of paper in
half
and you can tear it in half again you
know the most minimally curious person
is going to wonder
well what happens if i keep tearing it
apart right am i going to get to
can i keep tearing apart indefinitely or
sooner or later i'm going to get to
something that i can't tear apart any
further
though one of those two options seems to
be like the logically exhaustive
of possible choices and part of what
makes 20 20th and 21st century particle
physics so interesting is it actually
seems like that's
there's there's third and fourth options
out there that are just
so non-common sensical they don't really
fit into the way we the schemes that we
typically imagine
yeah yeah i
i have i i focus most of my energy on
teaching
evolution and origin of life science
that's what most of my
my main youtube channel is about and
because of that i have a lot of people
i have i talk with a lot of creationists
i get lots of emails from creationists
and i get a lot of
uh people trying to talk to me about
what is a theory
what is what is legitimate science and
what is pseudoscience this comes up
a lot and this is kind of the meat and
potatoes of
you know why i really want to have you
on here is to talk about
what is a scientific fact a scientific
theory and a scientific hypothesis
and how have ideas about those changed
over time
million dollar questions all right um
i'll i'll start by spoiling the end
about my
what i think personally and then i'll
just give the brief on that and then
i'll try to take a broader perspective
and sort of say how different
people thought about it uh i i think
that there really
there is no sort of simple answer to any
of those questions that there is no sort
of
clearly delineatable definable uh
uh things that you can put down uh that
specify what makes
something a either a fact in general or
a scientific fact in particular
uh and same for same for theory same for
hypothesis
same for paradigm uh all of these are
inherently
sloppy terms despite many people's noble
efforts to try to make them rigorous
and clearly defined um but uh
you know my sort of basic philosophical
groundwork is pragmatism
uh and and and i believe that meaning is
use and so if you want to know what
these terms mean you have to look at how
they're used
right and the terms are used by both
laypersons and scientists
in a plethora of ways uh that you that
don't sort of
uh fall down into any sort of single
particularly definable
uh neat piles uh it's sloppy and it's
blurry
but nonetheless it seems to have worked
out reasonably well so i don't think we
need to worry too much about that
yeah so one i have
if you watch like carl sagan richard
dawkins some of these more famous
science popularizers they seem to think
that there's a very clear difference
between
uh you know a scientific theory in a lay
person's theory
and i don't i don't really fully agree
with that um
and i i was thinking about this a lot
when i first started teaching
science and i i found your video on
lockatosh
and basically what he was saying was
exactly how i thought
i'd i've everybody seems to like carl
popper's idea
of a falsifiable scientific theory and
lockatosh comes along and giving it a
different explanation so i'm
yeah i'm hoping we can explore that a
little bit but
yeah so why don't we start with popper
because he he technically sort of
is is the first on the page here karl
popper was a 20th century
uh you know british philosopher and he
uh
was keenly interested in what you call
the problem of demarcation how do you
distinguish legitimate science from
pseudoscience
yeah uh and it's um and there's clear
sort of sociological reasons for why you
want an answer to this question because
lots of people claim to be scientists
but do so for impure motives right they
they want to
sell something they want to give
themselves artificial credibility
um one notable example of this karl marx
who claimed to be the isaac newton of
the social sciences
and it's pretty clear he wanted to don
the the lab coat of the scientist
in order to give his theories
credibility
which they they couldn't earn on their
own um
uh so yeah as as citizens
uh as consumers uh as intellectuals uh
being able to
neatly and clearly delineate who are the
legitimate scientists who we should give
this social authority to
and who are the cranks the crackpots of
the frauds of the charlatans
that we can deny this label to uh it's
really understandable why you want that
distinction
and popper's answer to this it's easily
the most famous answer to this question
he you know he
he makes the question popular and gives
the most famous answer uh and that's the
idea of falsification
as theory is only truly scientific if
it's incompatible with certain outcomes
in experience or an experiment uh
and uh because of the way this works
genuine science needs to be engineered
around trying to disprove ideas
according to at least sort of the naive
version of pop parianism
uh science never never either tries to
prove
any idea or succeeds improving any idea
all it does is
fail to disprove ideas uh and so it's
it's like a big sort of trial by fire
you just throw all your ideas in the
fire and the ones that survive
that test are the ones you hold on to uh
but you never stop throwing them in the
fire you know you pull it out and then
you find a different fire a hotter fire
different kind of a chemical fire and
you throw it into
that one uh and you go from there so
it's uh
uh uh it's this endless process of
trying to disprove ideas
um and did you wanna weigh on that or is
that should i pause here
no no no that's so i
i feel like so so he he gave us this
idea of falsification and i really like
this i mean this is what we try and do
when we're testing a
specific hypothesis is we try and figure
out um
if you're just trying to figure out why
your flashlight doesn't work it could be
the light bulb or the battery or the
switch
and you test them you know different
each individually until you figure out
which one it was
uh but the
so this makes a lot of sense the
the difficult thing of course is how do
you falsify a broad
theory like how do you falsify the
theory of gravity
or you know so i
last week with my guest he was he was
trying to say that
i can't remember why we were talking
about this but we were talking about
i was i brought up that that birds
if you don't understand how air pressure
works birds falsify the theory of
gravity right
so if you don't understand all this
other bit of science that's a
completely different field of study
really is the study of air pressure and
and aerodynamics you could think that
the existence of birds flying falsifies
the theory of gravity
and you could just throw the whole thing
away prematurely
because you haven't figured out this
other aspect of reality
that allows birds to fly and
it seems like it's you can't just
falsify
a broad idea with one experiment or
one fact but you can usually falsify a
really specific
statement you know a testable hypothesis
can easily be falsified
and i'm curious how you and how popper
would deal with things like that right
that that problem actually uh uh
hits popper on both ends uh both because
to use your example the flashlight um
you can disprove
the the the idea that uh the problem is
the bulb
but you can also successfully prove that
the problem is the batteries
right uh so you you can actually talk
about specific instances
you can both falsify and prove ideas uh
so if you're looking just at sort of
that that sort of specific claim
uh then popper fails because it is
possible to prove
uh uh that a particular idea is correct
um
but then yeah when you're going to the
general um again the fame the famous
catchphrase from thomas kuhn who
disagreed with popper is that anomalies
are not counter examples
um and every single scientific theory in
the history of science has had
anomalies right most of the time that's
not a serious problem because it's
it's human error or something like that
we have a contaminated sample or we
didn't calibrate our instruments
properly
you run the experiment again you modify
a couple things then you find where that
problem is and so and then the anomaly
is resolved but every so often uh it
doesn't
cooperate doesn't it it doesn't go away
uh and that's when things get really
interesting for the scientists
yeah um a minor a guy i i'm sorry to do
this but i gotta be
this is this is sort of one of those
little pet peeves of mine i think it's
it's a mistake to refer to the theory of
gravity uh
there are multiple theories of gravity
gravity is a phenomenon and
then we theorize about that phenomenon
right uh
and you know our our current best theory
is the general theory of relativity
uh so so i think when most people speak
about the theory of gravity
they probably mean the general theory of
relativity okay yeah
um i've i've got people asking if they
can
send questions in and absolutely we'll
we'll get to those questions
a little bit later so if if you do at
stated casually and make sure you put a
space between stated and casually
i will see those questions they'll be
highlighted in orange and yeah yeah i'd
love to get some
some uh some viewer questions in here so
okay so so what you're saying
anomalies are normal all all these broad
theories have anomalies in them
and that that's not a problem so what
what would popper say
is a falsifiable theory versus a
non-falsifiable theory i mean how
so you know we've got the theory of
evolution for example which is extremely
broad
and i've heard people try and
come up with ways to falsify it like
finding a rabbit in the camera in
but honestly that wouldn't actually do
it
it would be seen as an anomaly i would i
would
expect and then we have in the origin of
life we have an open-ended question
uh we're really driven by a desire to
figure out how
life emerged from chemistry and we're
not trying to
disprove that life could have emerged
from chemistry we're actually just
trying to figure out how
that happens at least that's what the
people who are working in the research
program that i work for
um that i work with at georgia tech
they're they're just trying to figure
out how this happened they're not
they're not actually questioning
whether or not it happened they're
they're trying to figure out how it
happened so
how did how how would popper see these
types of ideas
evolution and origin of life popper's
own ideas on this actually
transformed over the course of his
career um early on he actually used
darwinian evolution as an example of a
pseudoscience precisely for the reason
that a lot of creations sometimes
jump upon and as you noted because it
doesn't seem like there's
any sort of set or sort of definable set
of experiments that would make us just
give up on it because by its very nature
it's kind of
loose and compatible with a lot of
different results um
uh uh you know one of the a couple years
back in the discovery of tiktaalik which
was you know a missing link between
uh uh uh fish and amphibians
uh was hailed as uh incredible
supporting evidence for the theory of
evolution
but of course if uh if the scientists
had looked for fossils of tiktaalik and
hadn't found it
you know that would not have falsified
the theory of evolution um uh
you know the theory is compatible with
that because the theory says is that
some fossils are going to be preserved
some we're going to have records of some
species but not others you know
some of these fossils get lost in time
forever and we're never going to find
evidence that they existed
uh so when you have a theory structure
like that again the score of naive
poparianism
uh sort of is inclined to say that no uh
this isn't science science has to be
uh falsifiable if you can't say this
would prove the theory wrong and then
list specifically what that would be you
don't have a science
um popper uh was quite confident of that
when he was young because he had the
courage of his convictions
um but over over many years of
conversations with other philosophers
and with biologists
uh he came around to realize that uh uh
both he had misunderstood evolution and
also that his
sort of his early work was too
simplistic um
so uh um to the example you speak of
about about
uh the scientists that you're working
with uh researching uh the chemical
origins of life
again the naive poparianism would look
at that and say oh they're not doing
science because
they're they're just dogmatically
assuming that it it happens
somehow and they're only trying to
figure out how um and
from a certain point of view you can
sort of see why that's that does look
ugly right
you know if if if people are just
assuming uh at least part of their
conclusion and not testing it
um then you know what if they're wrong
about the thing that they're assuming
that shouldn't science
uh question everything shouldn't it
shouldn't it challenge everything
uh but again popper's big critic here i
think is thomas kuhn
who specifically comes back and says
look if if you actually tried to do
science like that you couldn't do
science at all
right science requires the closing off
of certain questions
if you are constantly testing every
single thing every single assumption
every single uh
idea if you're leaving that all open for
falsifiability
you're going to spend literally every
hour of your day going over
basic assumptions you're not going to be
able to get to to build up any kind of
research program
that allows you to to reach beyond uh uh
sort of the most basic things that
you're looking at uh so good science
at some point closes off and says okay
we're not going to debate this anymore
we have enough evidence
to say that this is settled science and
then we're going to build on that
settled science we're going to put our
efforts in our endeavors uh uh
in in what comes next starting with the
assumption uh that uh
we've done the science well enough to
establish this part so uh going forward
um and and that's i mean again if you if
you if you take it from
my point of view of the pragmatist's
point of view that's how science
is done by actual scientists and it
seems to be working out pretty well
uh yeah so if the proof is in the
pudding uh then uh
it it's the kind of naive poparianism uh
that says that this isn't science
it seems to be belied by the fact that
this is the process that
real scientists are using and it's
working out pretty well yeah
yeah i mean when we look at um origin of
life
researchers that i work with they're not
a chemical origin is the only thing that
they are specifically looking into
i find this very similar to to missions
like where we're going to put a man on
the moon
it's you have a bunch of scientists
working on this and you've got a mission
uh instead of really uh
instead of trying to disprove or prove a
theory
you're just working on this this goal
which
in origin of life chemistry is how do we
get
simple molecules to give rise to an
evolving entity that can actually go
undergo open-ended evolution and how how
would that have happened in the wild so
not only do we want a system that does
that we want a system that would do that
in a puddle somewhere or in some sort of
a natural environment
on the early earth or you know elsewhere
in the solar system
so this is this is what's driving them
and they've made consistent progress on
this they've
made consistent discoveries because of
this driving idea
and it's because of that history of
consistent consistent success
that people keep doing this and i feel
like um
well i think maybe someone's to talk
about wakatosh
and the um the competing competing uh
research programs with the theoretical
cores that he talked about
which which is what i found so so on
point it made so much more sense to me
than popper because
it is what i see real scientists doing
all of the time
yeah one way of framing lack lackitose
is as
as as an attempt to sort of synthesize
popper and
[ __ ] together uh into a more sort of
cohesive whole um and uh
so with that let me see a little more
quickly about about kuhn's
alternative contribution here then we'll
lead into lackatos from there
um so uh one thing one of the values
that kuhn stresses
that that drives science is this idea of
facundity um
an idea that generates more experiments
more theories more ideas
is going to just be naturally attractive
to scientists because it gives them
something to do
um any idea that sort of it seems to
have exhausted all possibilities and
there's nothing no more research to be
done
even if it looks like good science
scientists aren't going to be attracted
to it because
they don't get they don't get to build a
career off it they don't get to get any
grants they don't get to do any
interesting experiments so they're it's
just going to lie fallow and not go
anywhere
um so uh you know you have this idea
that's uh
that life originated from more basic
chemistry
um and that's an idea which clearly has
generated an awful lot of good science
you know many grants many papers many
books have been uh
experiments have been written and
performed uh uh on the basis of this
assumption
the contrasting assumption which is
again the the you know presumably the
one that left the creationists want to
say that it was
an act of god or some sort of divine
idea
isn't one that generates a lot of
scientific research uh uh
there's no doubt many have tried under
the discovery institute actually has
some legit scientists on their payroll
um uh that try to sort of spin this but
you know their papers don't get accepted
for publication and uh
when they publish books it's almost
always targeted at a religious rather
than a scientific audience
and it just has sort of scientific
trappings thrown over it um
so to go back to that pop-around
question why is it that the creationism
isn't really
science the one answer from kuhn would
simply be because it has no focus
uh it does not generate new scientific
experiments or new ideas
i'm sure there's gonna be a bunch of
creationists out there they're gonna try
to put forward their own counter
examples and more power to them for that
uh but uh
we'll we'll leave that aside for now
yeah um well
well just real quick on that note i've
actually found you know the discovery
institute markets themselves as like the
serious ones
whereas there's like ken ham and the
young earth that are
kind of these these old backwards
thinkers
and i actually find it's actually kind
of the opposite the discovery institute
does not
try to describe what the intelligent
designer is they don't
try and describe its attributes they
just they just
say that there's one that exists the
creationists are actually putting forth
things that could be really turned into
testable
hypotheses like if if there is a god and
that god has specific characters and we
could we should be able to go out and
look at nature and
find those i mean that and and they're
actually
um ken ham is actually now funding a
bunch of research into genetics trying
to find genetics that supports a
biblical interpretation
so i'm actually seeing interestingly
that
the young earth creationists are trying
to actually start
to do legitimate experiments and so on
they have their own journals because
their stuff won't get published
in uh mainstream journals but they have
they actually have people that are
trying to put together research programs
and i think that's really interesting
the discovery institute is not doing
that they're they're just making uh
basically just just making empty
arguments
and they took their hand when they do
that right uh in both sides uh
obviously i mean i'm not familiar with
the details of of ken ham's
uh research and stuff like that but i
would i would bet my house
uh that there's no result that's going
to make him change his mind no matter
what it is uh you know
yeah the experiment is is it only
designed to verify his preconceived
conclusion
uh but the discovery institute isn't
doing the the hard research as you say
precisely because they recognize that
the moment they try to sort of go out on
a limb uh which is always a big thing
for popper you have to go out on a limb
uh you got to put your weight on it uh
and risk embarrassment uh the second
they try to specify precisely what their
theory is
and make it empirically testable uh they
know that the branch isn't going to
support their weight and that's why they
very judiciously avoid
ever going out on a limb like that yeah
yeah it's it's been really interesting
to watch really smart people i mean i
i've i've actually spoken with michael
behe uh we emailed back and forth
uh and i've read his books
and he he does seem like he understands
it
but i i kind of feel like his first book
was sincere
and since then he's just been doubling
down um
when i it's it's interesting talking to
these people and
and getting there trying to get their
understanding because i'm michael b he
knows how to do research he's he's a
published scientist and he knows how to
how to do biochemistry it's just uh
it's it's bizarre to watch this happen
yeah i mean i think it's it's a common
mistake i think that a lot of
uh uh critics assume is that these
people must be stupid and i think that's
absolutely not true many of them some of
them are stupid of course but some of
any group of people is gonna be stupid
a lot of creationists including young
earth creationists are incredibly
intelligent uh back when i was living in
texas
two of the brightest students that i had
in the philosophy of religion class i
taught were young earth creationists
they were incredibly intelligent uh they
were just raised in an environment that
didn't allow them to question their sort
of you know religious
fundamentalism um and as such
it created uh um uh it created sort of a
closed hermeneut
uh
didn't let them uh think otherwise yeah
in michael bihi's case i mean again i i
i've read the men's stuff i don't know
him personally i haven't interacted with
him
but yeah i suspect that him and a lot of
other people
it becomes i don't mean to psychoanalyze
but there are other motivations not
necessarily just
profit although that can be a powerful
motive too but fame
and attention and respect i mean a lot
of people go
into science because they want credit
they want the steam they want to give
lectures
they want people to buy their books and
read their ideas and
if you find something that's a success
that can motivate you to double down on
an idea even if it isn't necessarily the
most
well-founded one scientifically and i
suspect something like that has happened
with bihae
so yeah yeah um
do we let's see do we need to talk about
i think we do need to talk a little bit
more about competing
uh research programs uh because
the the way that these broad theories
get tested i mean i
like i agree with people who say that
the theory of evolution is not really
falsifiable
but it certainly could be replaceable if
someone came up with a better theory
and and i i talk about uh miasma theory
being
being one of these really broad theories
that
really wasn't falsifiable the idea that
that bad air causes disease
it wasn't falsifiable but as soon as we
discovered bacteria we realized it's
bacteria that are
in many cases that are causing this bad
air and
uh so the the the germ theory
of disease replaced my asthma
without destroying the discoveries that
that that original theory had made
uh and so yeah it's a competing
competing research programs like how do
we think about these
yeah um uh richard dawkins once
uh i can't remember if it's his idea for
his idea he quoted one of his books but
he called evolution the only game in
town
yeah um and that's sort of one way of
of reframing the conversation uh so
rather than asking is evolution
falsifiable
you ask what is the alternative uh uh
and and whatever alternative you propose
it has to be able to account for all of
the phenomena
that the theory of evolution is
currently accounting for well
um but let me push back on that though i
mean
we could have we could have a theory
that accounts for
one third of it and maybe doesn't maybe
doesn't replace
the theory of evolution but explains
certain aspects
of what we see in biology in a better
way so this is
some people are trying to trying to
bring back lamarck for example
with epigenetics it doesn't seem that
promising to me but uh
you know something like that could could
show that
um darwinian evolution has a smaller
reach than we originally thought
and we've got this lamarchian style
evolution that's also happening
inside it so you've got you've got a
division and that way but there's not a
there's not a full replacement right uh
and that has happened in the in the
history of science right yeah you uh
uh um sometimes you know you get what's
called unification right where you have
separate spheres that are brought
together under the same umbrella
and sometimes you have you know division
where
something that you thought was sort of
coherently described by a single
uh conceptual scheme has to be fractured
into sub schemes in order to
in order to handle it or to make further
progress uh in it
um so it's yeah it's certainly possible
that some point in the future is
something that that will happen
in uh in biology or specifically with
regard to evolution
um but you know even when that happens
you know you you still have to be
preserved
either preserving or in some rare cases
eliminating phenomena proving that what
you thought was real was actually just
an illusion or something like that
yeah um but the the the
work that has been done heretofore has
to in some sense going to be accounted
for
by anything that's going to supersede uh
the the current
dominant paradigm to use coons phrase
um and you know as of now at least
they're they're they're
i think dawkins is right there is no
other alternative to
uh uh the theory of evolution that can
even begin to
to to account for these sorts of things
and
anything even approaching the the scope
that uh that darwin's
idea has managed to cover um so yeah i
mean
one thing which i think a a philosopher
or a scientist can do to the
creationists is just sort of push back
on them and say say look i'm
popper is wrong i'm not going to say
what you're doing in pseudoscience all
i'm going to say
is that right now you don't have a
developing uh
research program you know by all means
you want to spend you spend your money
on trying to make one happen
go for it uh but until you get something
off the ground
there is no competition in what you're
proposing
um and you know in a lot of ways i think
that can be
good for science to have people uh have
their own sort of
enclaves like that their own little
tribal theories as it were
most of the time those are dead ends and
don't go anywhere but on rare occasion
something useful and insightful might
develop from one of these
little little tribal ideas so who knows
uh
it's i'm not saying i think that in a
hundred years or more uh creationism is
going to dethrone evolution but there
might actually be
some legitimate scientific insights that
fall out ancillary to the research that
they fund
so yeah this is actually really
interesting because
the creationist movement has seemingly
unlimited
unlimited funding i mean they have a lot
of people that are willing to dump a lot
of money
into it and so you know i i met with
nathaniel jeansen
who is the geneticist that works for ken
ham
and uh i mean i i wished him luck on his
stuff
he i um he actually he gave me a tour of
the creation museum when i was there
and i he
he's not producing anything that i find
interesting right now but
he's got a ton of funding i mean there
are hundreds of employees that work for
ken ham
and there's they've got they've got
resources to pretty much
if he thinks he's onto something he'll
get money to
build a lab i mean the
the there's money there so sure
let's let's have an alternative research
program and if something
interesting ever comes out of that then
that's great
but i but this is also where things get
more complicated against sociologically
speaking
right um because okay in principle
it should just be the ideas right it
should just be uh the the quality of the
science
and nothing else should matter but in
practice uh if he or if anyone else
working for ken ham
ever got some you know found something
legitimately interesting and
scientifically solid empirically back
and so forth
vetted thoroughly and then tried to
publish it uh you know
a huge swath of the scientific
establishment is going to just look at
his name look at his association and not
even bother to read his paper
because they're going to say your
reputation precedes you
uh and they might acknowledge in
principle that yes that it is
if their ideas are good then it doesn't
matter where it comes from but in
practice they have only so many hours in
the day
uh there's only so many papers that they
have time to read why waste time on a
paper that
that they know by reputation is almost
certainly going to be hacky [ __ ]
um when they could be reading something
that has a better reputation
and uh because of those sorts of uh
limitations those sorts of
shortcuts that we use to try to sort of
as a heuristic to sort
good quality stuff and bad quality stuff
sometimes
we might lose some legitimate scientific
insights but you know that's just the
nature of life being finite
yeah uh i think i think
anyone who's outside of mainstream
science and they want to contribute
i think they just need to be aware that
that exists like
the science is definitely it's it's a
culture there's there's humans in it
that have their favorite other humans
and
uh there's there's been this
among popularizers of science there's
been this thing that oh no science is
always self-correcting it always follows
the best
the best information but obviously
that's not true once once you've got
once you have have fame in the
scientific community people are going to
read your papers more
uh when you know once you have a nobel
prize people are going to listen to you
more
uh things things like this
so uh it's it gets tricky
uh but really i mean science is it's a
human it's a
society it's a it's a human cultural
invention
and
you just have to know that making a
discovery is only half
half of the uh the problem you you also
need to get it seen
and understood by people and i see a lot
of uh
a lot of people who are jaded with the
scientific community
because of this but it really is just a
fact of human nature that this is how
all societies seem to work right yeah
ideas have to be sold
and uh you know some of the some of the
best ideas
languished not because you know this is
true in philosophy as well as it's true
in science
uh not because the underlying ideas or
the evidence for them are bad but just
because they don't get a good champion
um rather famously um
you know charles darwin wasn't terribly
good at selling his own ideas he was
kind of a taciturn man uh and it
required oh gosh what's his name
darwin's bulldog um
uh oh god i'm just forgetting his name
too
yeah i wrote a whole article on him once
yeah
uh thomas henry huxley yeah uh and he
you know he got that nickname precisely
because
he was you know he championed it in
public uh and he was the guy who did a
much better job of selling it
uh to both the scientific establishment
and to a large extent to to
the masses as well uh and without
thomas henry huxley uh uh uh and ideas
like darwin's
it's not they wouldn't have been
discovered or they wouldn't have been
accepted but it would have taken a lot
longer
it would have been a slower going
process so i would actually push back on
you a little bit there when you say
science is not self-correcting i think
it is it's just
it it takes a much more circuitous route
to get there yeah i think
things like fame can blind people and a
lot of people will you know read an
article and go
there's something seems wrong with this
but then again this guy's a nobel prize
winner so i probably just don't
understand something
uh and so they toss it aside rather than
challenging
right we're seeing but we're seeing that
right now with um
the there was this nobel prize winner
who says that there's an
hiv snippet in the genetic code of
coveted 19. of stars cove too uh
and that the guy who's saying that is
he's basically giving no evidence for it
and people are believing it because of
his credentials
right uh well i would hope that that
that scientists aren't believing it but
no no no they're not it's it's the
public and it's
it's different news articles like oh
nobel laureate and
everybody in science especially people
who know that guy they're like oh my
gosh this is the guy who believes that
water
understands human emotions and stuff
right um
and that's something else yeah piece of
general science literacy here is that
you know
you often see these headlines nobel
prize winner says x whenever you see
that
always check what they won the nobel
prize for because more often than not
the field in which they won the nobel
prize is a different one than they're
opining on in that article
so right uh yeah so
i've the other thing that you hear a lot
when you're talking to scientists is
they'll tell you that uh
you know theories can change when
the person leading the field dies
like yeah so science progresses one
funeral at a time yeah
uh i can't remember who said that but
yeah that was a and there's there's a
lot of truth to that right um
again it's a sociological observation if
you are a a graduate student
or a post grad and you're trying to
decide where you're going to invest your
career
you could go for the field which has
been thoroughly explored by the previous
generation
and maybe you'll make a modicum
contribution extend it slightly
or you can you can put all your chips in
this new upstart uh
area idea where you can make a huge
impact and so
for sociological reasons a lot of young
scientists will gravitate towards the
the new hotness
instead of the old established theory
and then eventually the old school dies
off and sometimes that's that's how the
scientific revolution happens it's not
because there's
it's falsified in any potperian sense
it's just because uh the interests and
and the sociological motivations shift
in a different direction
yeah uh you know tips for anyone who
might want to become a scientist
uh noam chomsky is about to die well not
about to die but he's
he will probably within your lifetime
and
the uh linguistics is a field that is
very much dominated by him
um nobody's allowed to like really
publish anything that's too far against
i say allowed but it doesn't really get
published if it's
in too much conflict with him but
there's a lot of
pressure building up in that field uh
for that sort of rain to end so
um i've i've i've got some linguistics
friends here that that complain about
that a little bit
so uh this is something we see in every
every field of science it's uh
it's pretty interesting because i i had
a more
i would say when i first got into this i
had a more pure
view of science being being progressive
on a much faster level than it actually
is it really does take
serious arguing and serious debates and
sometimes a funeral
for a new idea to get to really be taken
seriously and get a lot of funding
we're starting to see something
interesting in biology right now which
is
the templeton foundation is coming in
with
a lot of money and they're funding a lot
of research and they don't
they're not interested in the things
that academia has been interested in
traditionally
and a lot of biologists are upset with
this they're saying you guys are funding
garbage studies
uh and i actually just think this is
interesting like you've got a bunch of
money coming in from a
completely different source and you're
gonna see the field shift for better or
for worse
into very different very different ideas
um so i'm i i don't have solid opinions
on whether or not that's good or bad it
just
to me it just seems really interesting
yeah uh the templeton foundation also
funds a lot of work in philosophy too
and i've known some philosophers who've
gotten money from them uh
and i've pulled them aside and asked
them like you know what's the process
like and in particular what i'm
interested in
is there is there any i inclination at
all that they're trying to put their
thumbs on the scales to push the results
in one way or another
and to a person i mean i haven't done a
survey that's what i've talked to
several people but to a person
they have said that there's no
interference at all that that
they they fund it they want to see what
the results are they're not trying to
nudge uh things one way or the other um
i i assume that's true of their
scientific funding as well although i
don't know any scientists who've got
taken about so that to me is
is an encouraging uh thing to hear yeah
jerry coyne came out saying that
scientists should not accept money from
them
good scientists should not accept money
from them but the thing is they're
giving out money every
year whether or not good scientists
apply for it or not so if good
scientists are not applying for it then
cranks are going to apply for it and
they're going to get it because they're
the only ones applying for it so i think
that this is a
that's one of the most ridiculous
protests i've ever heard of like let's
not take free money are you crazy
and while i i don't know jerry
draycoin's bank book looks like my
impression is that he's a person who's
never had any difficulty getting funding
for his work
so it's again it's kind of a bourgeois
thing to say like you know when you're
swimming
in cash which again he may not be i'm
assuming so maybe i'm wrong about this
but
if he is if he if he has all the funding
he needs it's pretty
uh it's a view from the from the
expensive seats to tell the hoi polloi
that they shouldn't take cash from
people who are giving it out
in order to fund their research because
he's got all the funding he needs yeah
yeah yeah and yeah i think you know if
good scientists aren't applying for that
money
we're going to get a bunch of woo woo
getting published
because templeton foundation paid for it
so
anyway i think it's really interesting
to see these these private groups coming
in and funding
uh and just seeing how this stirs the
pot a little bit
and uh mixes things up it's really cool
i've got a couple of questions
uh but before we we go into
viewer questions i want to just kind of
try and
summarize um what we've talked about so
far so
this big popular idea is that
a scientific theory is a super well
established
idea that is falsifiable
that's kind of what what popper has
brought us and if you look on wikipedia
you look at the definition of a
scientific theory
they talk about it has to be a super
well established
scientific idea that explains a bunch of
data but
what what we're kind of seeing here is
that's not really the case
you've got lots of competing theories a
theory
is is is an idea that that ties a bunch
of facts together and helps us create
new hypotheses that we can then go test
the theory itself might be might not be
directly falsifiable
but it's um you can have competing
theories
and one that leads to what did you say
was the the fecundity
of the the theory the theory that's
that's producing more testable
hypotheses and then producing more
new observations the the uh the
collection of more
more facts is the one that ends up
gaining uh scientific consensus so
an established scientific theory is
you know the you know germ theory uh
theory of evolution these these are
established scientific theories but
there are lots
of other scientific theories that are
being tested that are much smaller
maybe don't have scientific consensus
behind them yet is that
is that all fair what i've said yeah and
i'll give a
quick concrete example which uh that i
haven't used before if you think about
string theory for example in
in in physics this is def this does not
meet that criteria you talk about being
well established empirically grounded
and foundational stuff like that
um but it's still called the theory and
some people complain about that because
they say
it shouldn't be called a theory but
those those voices are generally in vain
uh
it's it's it's taken on the label of a
theory
because it has this kind of facility
there's lots of
research to be done in string theory uh
even though it's mostly theoretical work
and
and not a whole lot of empirical work um
so yeah again
meaning is use the way both scientists
and lay people use the
term theory string theory is an example
of a theory even though it does not
read that meet those more stricter
criteria that you were suggesting
yeah so so let's play with this a little
bit because
one of the questions i got was on
twitter the other day um
and that is should scientists call
theories something else should they
invent a new word for this
established scientific theory because
you know
your uncle with a theory about what
really happened on 9
he's using the word theory very
differently but i
i actually actually don't think he is
using it
that differently because you could
actually turn your
uncle's crazy 911 conspiracy into
a research program if you wanted to it
would just require
um you know coming up with testable
hypotheses
and starting to do the research am i am
i right in that or
am i way off base here well i mean you
you could take it in that direction and
uh again because uh a 911 conspiracy
theory
is about a sort of particular historical
event uh it's going to take on different
contours and somebody's trying to find a
general principle or a law of science or
something like that
um but yeah i mean you know if you're
willing to extend the idea of theory
into historical research which
i certainly am that certainly i think
becomes
uh you could put a research program
around that
but it would almost certainly be a
degenerating program within a within a
matter of
hours if not days because the the
hypotheses that throws up
are going to immediately run into uh to
counter evidence
right and and and one of the hallmarks
of a degenerating research program
is when you start doing hand waving
maneuvers to try to explain away
contradictory evidence that oh well
we shouldn't expect that anyway because
of x y and z and then you modify this
hypothesis over there in order to
accommodate this counter evidence
um and while i'm certainly no expert on
either 9 11 or 9 11 conspiracy theories
i've seen enough about them
uh to know that that there's a lot of ad
hoc maneuvering going on amongst the
theorists to explain away
things uh that can
that contradict their way of thinking of
course they push back and say the same
thing's true of the
the predominant narratives but yeah
let's not wait into
the details of that example yeah it it
really does get difficult
to when people start arguing about
what is science and what is not science
it really does get difficult because
the the differences can be
fuzzy right and
people and people doing mainstream
science sometimes do bad things they
sometimes do make their
data fit the conclusion that they want
to
to fit i mean there's tons of examples
of this
with uh you know research that's not uh
reproducible and so on so it's
things are not so black and white i feel
like if you get on the internet and you
start reading forums and debates about
what is science and what's not science
people seem to think that this is a
super clear-cut black and white
situation but
what i'm seeing is that there's a lot of
fuzzy borders on all of these things
yeah i mean one obvious example here
would be um
the two scientists fleischmann and pons
i think of their names are called in the
1980s who who claim to have discovered
cold fusion
um they made a huge splash they were
legitimate scientists they had
you know solid reputations um and it was
one of those things where if what they
said held water then it would have been
a huge
important revelation um but
the second people tried to sort of
replicate their findings that were
unable to do it
um and so you know you can sort of ask
this question was that science or was it
pseudoscience
and it's kind of hard to say i mean on
the one hand it actually
it seems to pass poppers tests because
their claims were falsifiable
uh the people who tried to replicate it
fail to replicate it and so it it's
science it's just
it's it's failed science or something
like that right um so
yeah uh and then you have um well i
i could talk a lot about that all day
but i i want to this question here
um we're we just we just passed an hour
so
i i want to be really respectful of your
time i don't know how much
you have uh 10 more minutes to do some
of these questions i i have plenty of
time
at all you need so my question for dr
miriam
miriam uh let's see
is if science assumes a natural
explanation
rather than a supernatural one or if
science simply uses observation to
better understand everything
so does it i'm sorry does it assume a
natural
supernatural or does science assume a
natural
explanation for everything rather than a
supernatural one
or is science simply based on
observation
uh do we even have to worry about the
difference between natural and
supernatural i think is what he's
asking okay got it um there's there's
been some interesting work done recently
on sort of broad speaking the field of
naturalism and one of the things which
people have been borrowing down to in
the last
decade or so it seems to me is that we
don't really have a very clear
understanding of what the hell we mean
when we say the word
natural um so there's a sort of naive
conception of natural versus
supernatural
but when you push on that rigorously
analytically
it's not all clear uh what it would mean
uh
uh
you know so you know if you had
something which you know
would uh as the term is you know sort of
naively used
you'd say well that's that's
supernatural that's a miracle uh how do
we sort of
know that it's supernatural as opposed
to just a part
a different part of the natural world
that we don't yet understand
um so i i i
don't think that science assumes that
the world is a natural world
the everything is natural that they're
only studying the natural world
um i i think that there isn't a sort of
clear conceptual alternative to what
science could be studying
um it's only when people like
you know creationists or what have you
come along and try to insist that there
is another alternative the supernatural
explanation
which again in their defense was a
default assumption that many people
throughout uh uh
civilization have have made for
thousands of years prior to now so it's
like they don't have a tradition to fall
back on
um but uh one of the ways i think of
understanding the success of science
isn't as saying well okay we're gonna
ignore the supernatural and just
study the natural but rather of being a
series of tools which has got have
gotten us clarity to understand
uh that there is one thing that science
ex science studies and that's the world
and anything in the world that you can
use science to study science is going to
study
uh so if you want to call this thing
supernatural
science would be happy to study it if
you could show them how they do that
um but there doesn't seem to be any
examples that i know of
where where people said this is
supernatural this is part of the world
and science can study it
um uh that at best that's a sort of a
a armchair philosophy endeavor not a
empirical science endeavor
yeah yeah i i've
my my thoughts on this had just been
that you know
you can't even there's this
there's methodological naturalism which
is what my guest last week was talking
about he was saying that science
science scientists are not allowed to
study the supernatural therefore if
there's a supernatural explanation
science is not equipped to ever figure
that out and my
my thinking on this is just that it
doesn't
whatever a claim is it can be studied
you could you can design a research
program to to test hypotheses derived
from that claim so i don't
i don't feel like it even makes sense to
even try and think about what
supernatural is versus
natural if if there's a claim just study
it just
follow it follow it as deeply as it goes
and uh
so that this this claim of a
supernatural creator
certainly it's possible but how do you
study it
wha what's what's the research program
that you would put together
and is that research program being
productive or not
and i just haven't seen creationists
come up with a research program to study
the origin of life based on a creator
that no one's trying to
study the nature of god uh
in a scientific way that i've seen and
so i
just i'm waiting um but i haven't seen
it so
yeah i'm inclined to agree i think it's
kind of a mistake for people to to
double down so much on methodological
naturalism
um uh because
yeah it's i don't think it's true that
scientists are committed to
methodological naturalism i i i think
that the question of naturalism doesn't
really enter the work of most scientists
minds
um it enters the work of certain people
who
like metaphysics um both philosophers
and theologians
um but scientists practicing scientists
aren't really concerned about those kind
of underlying metaphysical questions
they're concerned about
you know whatever is showing up in in
their their particle colliders or their
test tubes or whatever um
and so again my my method here my
philosophical method is to boil down to
uh to kind of pragmatism and sort of one
pragma
standard pragmatic method here say
imagine two worlds
one in which everything is natural and
one in which some things are natural and
some things are supernatural
and the question is if i were to
randomly put you in one of these two
worlds
what would you look for to distinguish
which one you were in
which world uh what experiments which
experiences would you seek out to say
okay
i'm in the completely natural world
versus i'm in the semi-natural
semi-supernatural world
um and unless you can say what the
difference between those two worlds
would be
experienced from the inside out then
there really is no distinction to be had
here
right and i think that's how most
scientists go about to go about their
questions you know
you know they're studying what they can
study they're studying what they can see
in front of them
and what they can measure and and what
their experiments and their their
uh their apparatus allows them to reach
and you know uh they're not interested
in classifying as natural or
supernatural they're just saying this
is what we have it's only when outside
factors like theologians or some or
politicians or philosophers come along
and say oh yes but where's the room for
god uh
in all this um and as uh laplace once
famously said to uh to napoleon when
when napoleon saw laplace's model of the
solar system he said where's where's
room for god mccloth said i have no need
of that hypothesis
yeah the vast majority of scientists
just have no need of the hypothesis of
the supernatural but they
likewise don't have any need for the
hypothesis that's all natural either
all this is this is the experiment
right uh yeah i'm glad we're
i guess we're on the same page with that
so uh i've got
so that that that question came from
andrew [ __ ] and the next one comes
from free willing skeptic
how do you respond to people who say
science is also a kind of belief
because we are just taking scientists
word for it
yeah i mean there's a sense in which
that's true i mean
a kind of belief i mean that that sort
of seems like it's trivializing it's
reducing it but i don't think that's
true
beliefs are kind of part of the basic
currency of epistemology here
um uh there's nothing bad about being a
belief
uh but if he means like merely a belief
as opposed to knowledge or something
like that
um i think that
all all epistemology at some point or
another
except for very basic minimal things
that right in front of you falls down to
some kind of social epistemology
the vast majority of the things that you
think you know
you know because other people have
written about it or
taken photographs of it or given reports
and you're trusting them to have not
falsified those that they're
what they've written or to photoshop the
photos or something like that
um so uh uh if you're going to say that
that science is uh somehow epistemically
problematic because we rely on other
people
then you're throwing a lot of baby out
with the bathwater because there's very
little that you can believe in any
field um and and so you're going to be a
pretty die hard skeptic at that point
and i think he said that the user's name
was free willing skeptics so maybe he's
comfortable with that maybe he doesn't
mind that kind of
uh broad he or she doesn't mind that
kind of a
broad deep skepticism um well most
people think
that well yeah i i think um you know
what is it nolius in verba is the is
this
is the saying of the royal institution
which means take no one's word
society yeah yeah the royal society and
and they were
this this idea is really foundational to
modern science is that
all of the conclusions that we draw or
tentative
conclusions that we draw in science have
to be based on observation
and there certainly is a level of trust
like you trust the scientists that they
actually observe the thing they say they
observed and that they're reporting on
but also you try and set everything up
so that you can go double check that
um so what really the science
the modern science has this distrust in
people's uh taking people's word for it
i mean that's
that's what it was you have to show us
show us the data
and and then show us how you link that
data together to draw your conclusions
and then we'll take you seriously then
we'll publish your paper if you don't
show us the data
we don't care what you're saying and of
course you have to there has to be a
a level of trust there when i when i get
uh an image of from a microscope from an
electron microscope
i have to trust that someone didn't draw
that in the computer program like
you can do that now you can make fake
ones but uh
there's we are asking for
observations in science that's what
we're asking for and that's what we
expect of of of researchers
yeah it's like that famous line that
ronald reagan had right trust but verify
um and uh and what
one of sort of lack of tosh's ideas is
that science gets its power from the
balance between open-mindedness and
closed-mindedness
yeah um and it you can sort of repurpose
that to say it gets its power from the
balance of cooperation and trust
and skepticism uh you you want enough
skeptics in the community that are going
to go back and double check
uh other people's work uh but you also
need to have people who are willing to
tentatively trust that they did their
work right
and and proceed forward from there yeah
um
uh so yeah it's it's it's neither this
sort of naive picture we're just
taking people's word for it nor is it
the idea that we're these sort of
die-hard skeptics who are going to
question and double check and triple
check everything
it's a balance between those two uh that
you know that shifts depending on the
particulars
i mean like some of the you know the
again
the the the the one side of that can be
kind of naive in some ways about how
they
they they demand that you show them the
data and you demand that make it
replicable you've probably heard about
what's what's sort of been dubbed the
replication crisis
going on right now in a lot of fields
most notably psychology
um but a lot of the times the response
to this when someone you know when
someone's
paper from 20 years ago is if they
attempt to replicate it
um usually the original paper author
will say something along the lines of
well no you just you didn't do it right
you know you you attempted to replicate
it but
uh you didn't replicate it right and
they might because it's part of my fault
i didn't write my
my methods section of my paper well
enough that you were able to follow it
um you know and so there's a back and
forth over exactly where is the
breakdown
was the original experiment flawed was
the replication flawed
um and you know it takes a long time to
sort out the
all these sorts of problems right um and
so
to a large extent we you know scientists
and
scientifically affiliated people uh have
to be patient
and trust that in the long run truth
will act in the long run
uh we will be able to to to resolve not
necessarily every question
in any particular question yeah there's
a really interesting problem right now
with
sars cove to the the virus causing kova
19
in that uh the
the sequence that we found that's most
closely related to it in bats
was discovered in like 2013
but it wasn't published until after
this infection broke out and its
sequence wasn't
and it was published from research
it was the the genome was sequenced back
in like 2013
and then the virus the actual sample was
thrown out
so all we have is this scientist's word
on what the sequence was when she
sequenced it
years ago and people are starting to be
like okay wait a minute
how do we know you're not lying to us
how do we know that this
um this is legitimate at all like this
it's kind of like uh when
joseph smith got the uh the book of
mormon from an angel and then the angel
took it back
um and all were left is joseph smith's
translation of it right
so right so you have
what what would have worked perfectly
what we would have trusted is if there
was a
a paper from 2013 that pub had the
genome already published and now we have
this
this virus that's come out that that
historical
sequence would have been enough evidence
for us to say okay there's no way you
lied
but now that there's a lot so much
writing on this
people are saying wait a minute are we
are we sure we trust this group
um and it's it's interesting to see that
happen that
that kind of distrust happening in the
scientific field yeah and and not
knowing the details of the case
uh you know from what you just said
right there that sounds like a good
example of where
uh some simple scientific judgment has
to come into it right
if you don't have uh this positive
evidence one way or the other
you have to trust the judgment of the
scientific community
you know is this researcher or this
research group are they generally
reliable do they seem to be the kind of
people who would make something like
this up do they have a record of
misbehavior in the past and so forth
is there pressure on them right now to
lie right exactly
uh and so all those things which are not
in this strict
sense in the poparian or the empiricist
sense uh
questions about of science are
inescapable for the actual process of
science this is part of the sort of the
social nature of sciences we have to
make judgment calls sometimes
about whether or not to trust or whether
or not to disregard
yeah i've got another comment from
uh youtuber meek and pure
they say to do science you have to
believe your senses are reliable
that science is reliable and that the
laws in the universe are consistent
this starts with a priest presupposition
that those beliefs are true
which is faith i don't know if you it
wasn't really a question but
uh do you have any uh any response to
that
yeah we can roll with that um i mean
that line of thinking is uh you know
definitely has a long
and deeply rooted sort of skeptical
tradition um
you can you can find traces like uh that
kind of thinking going back to the
the pre-socratics even uh and
philosophically speaking you know again
if you're interested in armchair
philosophy and uh that kind of stuff i
think that
you can have lots of interesting
conversations about that um
but uh i i would disagree with the con
with the use of the word faith there
just because i mean again it's not that
again meaning is used sometimes people
use the word faith that way and so so
that's not completely fair but generally
speaking i like to preserve the word
faith
uh uh to to to mean something a little
bit more
existential in nature it's not just a
belief that you hold without evidence
it's
something more along the lines of a
belief that gives your uh gives you
purpose or meaning or something along
those lines
but that's a quibble about the word
faith i think the the broader skeptical
point
is maybe i think more what they're
getting at um and i i think that
there's there's a kind of i mean in the
modern era that way of thinking is sort
of cartesian based
uh you know it starts with this
assumption that it's you you can
you can rationally doubt all sorts of
stuff including that your own senses are
reliable
um but that kind of cartesian skepticism
i think actually is sort of
fundamentally flawed and in a lot of
ways
cause needless headaches for a lot of
modern philosophy um
and again the the pushback we come back
to again is my sort of pragmatist method
here it's like okay
imagine two universes one in which my
senses are not reliable
and one in which my senses are reliable
um uh
uh in the sort of absolutist sense in
which i i assume the question to be
asking
throw me in both of these worlds and
then have me figure out which one i'm in
uh if if there isn't something that i
can do to distinguish a world
from which i can trust my senses from a
world in which i can't trust my senses
then i'm not sure exactly what if what's
being asked here uh there's obviously
certain circumstances which i can't
trust my senses
illusions are real um i i dream on
occasion which obviously you're part
what motivated
card of course is the dream skepticism
but in all those instances
you can tell what the where it breaks
down
right if what you're imagining is a
situation in which your dream
is so consistent uh that uh uh
it's you can never tell it apart um you
know it's
sort of the matrix scenario uh the
perfect matrix and the actual movie of
course the matrix is
fallible too but if you imagine a
perfect experience machine
uh or the simulation hypothesis which is
another popular idea that gets thrown
around these days
um you know any one of these scenarios
is one in which you know
you can you can say you can't trust your
senses
um but i don't think that's true i think
you know
you can't trust your senses to get you
to base reality but what use do we have
of base reality
all that we care about is consistent
experiences all we care about
is uh the way in which the world appears
to us
i see no reason to want or need to go
any further than that
as long as the universe appears
consistent to us and our theories
make consistent sense of that then
that's all we need i i really like that
that all we care about is consistency
and and really we we've we've observed
consistency that doesn't mean that
things are always going to be consistent
right of course the sun might not rise
tomorrow
so but but we've seen it and and
we're basing our understanding of the
universe on this consistency i mean it
seems to be that
our senses evolved because there was
enough consistency that
um light was constantly bouncing off
things
in a similar way since before the origin
of the eye
and so natural selection was able to
shape the eye
around this constant
you know cue that the environment was
was transmitting
and so of of course our senses aren't
aren't perfect
i mean people will argue oh i'm not
i'm not even sitting at a desk this is
just a bunch of atoms that are
and and they're mostly space um
and the and so so everything that i'm
living is an illusion
but i i i kind of just see i
i see my own life really and i guess the
scientific project in general
as kind of just just waking up yeah i
woke up
my first memory is when i was three
years old i
and it was i was driving in my parents
car and i saw that the sun was going
down and i realized for the first time
that it goes down every single day
it's like whoa this happens that's my
first memory that's when i came online
right and the
the ever since then i've been slowly
kind of sort of like a drop of ink
spreading out through a
giant tablecloth i've slowly been able
to
to take in observations and try to
figure out what's going on here i have
no clue how big
the universe is i don't know how big
this tablecloth is it might go on
forever
but we're just kind of slowly spreading
from where we are
and trying our best to describe how
things work
so i really don't think that uh i don't
think that we
need the laws of nature to be true laws
that are consistent
in order to do science i don't think we
need that i don't think we need that
conclusion
i don't we're just figuring things out
from where we started
is how i see things yeah i think there's
there's a debatable question about
whether or not we can properly say there
are any such things that can properly be
called the laws of nature in the first
place
but that's maybe a conversation for
another day since you mentioned
one of your early experiences i want to
mention one of mine i don't think it's
my earliest memory but one early one i
remember the first time i put on
headphones
um and i was listening to something and
my brother was in the room
and i was trying to talk to him and i
screamed at him
because i i didn't understand that you
know the the the music was coming
through my eyes so i
i i naturally raised the volume of my
voice so i could hear myself
right and my brother very quickly
corrected me and pointed out you don't
need to scream you know it's loud for
you it's not loud for me
and that was like yeah where it clicked
for me that just because i'm
experiencing the world one way
doesn't necessarily mean that other
people are experiencing it the same way
um uh but quickly to circle back to the
questioner's point
one thing which i think is often not
appreciated by people who
put forward those kinds of skeptical
arguments is that skepticism itself
actually has to be funded by something
uh it's often presented as a a a sort of
a ground level right
you know this sort of cartesian idea
that you can strip away everything until
you get to the
the cogito is the foundation of the one
thing that can't be be doubted
um but that's i think it is mistaken in
order to have doubts in the first place
you have to have other beliefs that you
can contrast them with
uh you you you you don't get skepticism
for free
skepticism has to come from somewhere
you have to have a reason to doubt
in much the same way that you have to
have a reason to believe yeah
we got a really interesting question
from andrew t how important do you think
it is that scientists study and
understand the philosophy of science and
philosophy in general
many of my professors were often
philosophically illiterate
that's what he's saying uh yeah those
are more twitter that's it right okay uh
i would say
honestly it varies uh i think there are
certainly some scientists out there
who don't have any particular need for
the philosophy of science they can they
can do their work and they do it good
uh but those such scientists tend to be
kind of worker ants in my experience
um anyone who is interested in sort of
bigger picture questions like
how different areas of science interact
with each other uh you know how
uh you know chemistry and physics like
where the borderlines between that are
for example
uh they're gonna need to have some
philosophy of science
um anyone who's doing uh theoretical
physics needs to know philosophy of
science because
there's very theoretical physics by its
very nature is philosophy and science
it's it's it's theory um
anyone working in questions about
speciation or anything like that uh or
origin of life research
uh i think it needs to have uh
philosophy of science so uh yeah broadly
speaking again there may be exceptions
and maybe people who can get away with
it but it's only if they have
a very narrow question that they're
looking at
and that question doesn't doesn't
trespass on any uh sort of
deep philosophical questions most
scientists i think really
should uh would benefit considerably
from uh
having a philosophical education yeah
daniel
daniel dennett put it well i'm going to
paraphrase him she said there's no such
thing as philosophy free science there's
only science that has been done without
examining the philosophical baggage that
comes along with it or something like
that
yeah yeah well i i think we get a lot of
it that trickles through the ether
for free right i mean if if you're
trained in science and never thought
about the philosophy of science
you've actually been exposed to a bunch
of the philosophy of science it's just
not
you know i haven't talked about it that
way right like a scientist will look at
a bit of research and say that's crap
and that other one's good without being
able to articulate why
because they actually have a default
philosophical view as to what science is
which they got from somewhere
um but probably not by reading
reading philosophy right stephen
weinberg has this
uh uh analogy of the horse breeder
uh where he says that you know a
scientist can sort of tell a good theory
from a bad theory in much the same way a
horse breeder can
tell a good horse from a bad horse uh
they just they've seen so many champions
and they've seen so many losers
that they sort of naturally just
developed this intuitive sense of what's
gonna
uh which horses are gonna uh breed
winners and which ones aren't
um they don't necessarily have to
understand genetics or even the sort of
the underlying
components their their experience sort
of gives them enough of a perspective to
do that
um i think you can challenge that way of
thinking about science but there's
certainly at least something to it yeah
yeah
yeah i i would i would recommend anyone
who wants to get into science to
uh yes spend some time studying the
history
spend some time studying the philosophy
uh
i i think that a lot of people a lot of
the arguments about the philosophy of
science on the internet have to do
with should creationism be taught in
school like
that's where a lot of stuff that i hear
comes from
and i that's uh
that's an interesting question um
but i i think i think that what what
scientists
do and what they study is actually
different from that
um and and i feel like some of these
really strict definitions of what a
scientific theory is and so on i think
those have really been
pushed by people arguing that certain
things should be taught in school and
certain things should not
and i don't i don't feel like those
really strict definitions are maybe even
that
good for scientists to be worrying about
in general uh i don't know what your
thoughts are on that
i i have a certain kind of innate
skepticism towards people who get
interested in science principally as a
tool for bashing religion
um yeah and uh you know i think there's
a lot of old school
youtube atheists out there who don't
really care about evolution as such
they only care about proving that
creationism is wrong
um and you know there's nothing
inherently wrong about that of course
people get interested in science for all
sorts of reasons some of them are
mercenary like that
um and as long as they don't pervert the
science to suit their purposes
that's acceptable um but you know
there's so much more interesting about
science and the philosophy of science
besides yeah just the question
of how it intersects with religion uh
that i find to be a very sort of narrow
minded or even myopic point of view
uh uh if that's all if that's the only
reason you're interested in it
you're missing out on a lot of great
stuff yeah yeah
um um it seems like
we've gone through the questions if if
anyone has asked a question
and i didn't get to it please please
rewrite it in the comments because
comments
there's a lot of discussion going on
here side discussion
i've got andrew cummings says
just to clarify what dr miriam had said
one professor told me that supernatural
is quote
it can't be natural therefore it's
supernatural
how would you respond to that well it's
kind of circular definition right
um so no it's i'll try to breathe a
little more charity into that so there's
a you can do sort of a process of
elimination right uh
if you have a phenomena and you trust
the phenomenon is real it's not an
illusion
and you exhaust every possible thing
that you could say
is a natural explanation for that
phenomenon then the only conclusion left
is it has to be supernatural
um which sounds great in the abstract
until you try to sort of pin it down in
practice
um and this is something that david hume
talked about way back when right you
know if you have an alleged miracle
and you exhaust every possible
explanation that you can think of
than a natural explanation you can think
of uh then you're left not with
one possible conclusion name that's
supernatural but two possible questions
either it's supernatural or
there's a natural explanation that i
can't think of and
and hume gives this sort of armchair
argument that the second conclusion is
always the better one
um because we know for example that
people
you know if you have an alleged miracle
we know that people fake
miracles sometimes you know we in our
own experience we know that people
will manufacture evidence to try to make
it look like a miracle happened
and even if you can't figure out how
this particular alleged miracle was
manufactured
since you know that kind of thing
happens but you don't know
that ever real miracles ever actually
occur the rational conclusion is to say
this is probably a fraud
or maybe not a sort of fraud maybe i'm
misunderstanding something or maybe this
is something here that's perfectly
natural but uh
i'm limited in my capacities to figure
out what it is um
now now again there's this push back to
hume's argument there obviously i'm not
suggesting that that is the the end-all
be-all of the conversation
um but it it just goes to show that that
kind of process of elimination argument
doesn't really get you very far
because you're never going to be at a
place where you can say definitively we
have ruled out all possible natural
explanations
right there's always going to be more
right i mean well german
the discovery of germs is a really good
example of this because we thought that
we had no clue what was causing diseases
before we really understood that germs
exist
and we exhausted all
all natural explanations and so people
put forth supernatural explanations
and i i suppose that was fine without
hell i i i think i think the problem
with jumping to a supernatural
explanation really quickly
is that it stops you from doing more uh
actual investigation right but it
doesn't have to right i mean again it's
yeah
and this is why again i think the line
isn't really all that meaningful
um you know you could imagine a
supernatural proposal that says
something along the lines of people get
sick because they offend god
right right illness is punishment now
set aside the fact that the book of job
specifically
says that that's not the case right uh
you know this person who did not offend
god but got sick anyway
um but set that aside right so our our
operating theory is that is that people
get sick because
they they they sin or because they
offend god in some way well that's a
testable hypothesis
right right uh uh at least in principle
you know you you get a control group of
people who offend god who sin somewhere
then another people who don't
but then of course you know it really
quickly breaks down right people will
say things like well all people are
sinners well then you can't have a
control group and now it's no longer a
testable hypothesis
and now it's no longer a one that we can
call scientific
but in principle if you could right if
you had the control group of people who
sin
and those people get sick and then
people who don't sin and they don't get
sick
uh you know you at least have now a
research program that you can build on
you can start looking into in more
detail
trying to figure out what the nuances
what the details are
you can call that supernatural you can
call that natural i i
wouldn't care what you call it you know
if it worked out that way
here's something to study here's
something we can dig our teeth into
natural
supernatural who gives a damn we can
study this right interestingly the
templeton foundation's funding a lot of
prayer research
as to does does prayer work to heal
uh the sick and uh they found out oh
their research right now the stuff
that's been published says that the
answer is no but
you could you could really you could
look at that
those research the the experiments that
they set up and there's actually lots of
ways to
critique those and say well you know
actually in this case they they were
they were they were studying whether or
not praying for someone who is sick
helps
and my question with that experiment is
how do you know that the people in your
control group that we're not being
prayed for how do you know that someone
wasn't praying for them because
right yeah like what if the pope said
i bless everyone who's sick today and
the whole universe
to get better i mean you don't know so
these experiments get really tricky um
and
the but you can you can technically
study these things you can set up
experiments to study these things and i
don't
yeah i i agree with you that trying to
trying to dis distinguish between
supernatural and natural is
is a kind of a fool's errand um
we could set up experiments to study any
claim that's being made
you could you should be able to set up
an experiment to study it
another question or yeah a question from
rahini vinokota he says i'm 11 years old
i like science i try to debunk mostly
christian and hindu creationists
do you think creationism will increase
creationist movements i guess do you
think that they're going they're getting
stronger
becoming more more common or do you
think that that's diminishing
they're they're 11. that's when they're
pretty precocious 11 year old power too
um uh yeah i mean gosh i don't know um
again i'm not a sociologist um my my
study of creationist movements
such as it is is entirely armchair i
don't know if they've been
growing or contracting in recent years i
i do believe that religious belief in
general is on a
very gradual decline or at least
commitment to organized religion
um so yeah i mean i
i don't know i i i have no i think
particular insight
to that uh i would hope that it wouldn't
um because i don't think it's
it's intellectually honest or or or
uh generative of interesting uh
scientific or philosophical questions
but uh you know oftentimes
religious movements religious ideologies
can flare up and be very popular for a
long period of time so maybe
maybe we'll head into one of those
periods maybe we won't i don't know
yeah i like this talking about it as a
flare-up
like it's a like it's herpes or
something
um yeah uh and he he also asks
uh can you disprove the garuda bell
people say it's 300 million years old
and this is a bell that was found
well so people there's a bell embedded
in coal
and that coal is dated at 300 million
years old that the
the coal seam is and uh
i i would say that that whole situation
is a little bit silly
there's lots of ways for objects to get
stuck in
coal coal coal can dissolve and reform
uh
quite easily and so there's there's lots
of ways to get something
silly going on there and then try and
use that in a creation museum
type thing to say that this this is this
disproves
evolution there was another example of
this there was a
a human bone inside of a foot
embedded in stone and it was this white
stone and it was just this lime
it was it was it was again it was it was
this type of powder that can easily
dissolve and then re-solidify
and this was actually this boot this
fossilized boot
was in a creation museum it was on tour
and then the
uh police ended up confiscating it
because it was it was evidence in a
mate possibly a murder or some sort of a
death or like where the heck did you get
this this is a fresh human
foot you can't have this
and it was just it was just covered in
essentially mud right
uh and yeah and so uh yeah i mean i
don't know the specifics of either of
these instances
but i think again the general
philosophical principle here again is
thomas coons anomalies are not counter
examples
um there's lots of good scientific work
that shows
how you can generate anomalies how
otherwise reliable
uh detectors can be thrown off uh from
measuring the thing which
under normal circumstances they measure
uh you know the world is a complex place
uh you can get contaminated samples
which will then
test at millions of years old or maybe
only dozens of years old
um but it's not that's not the case
because it's genuinely that old but
because this the sample has been
contaminated by something
potholer54 on youtube has several
examples of these in his series
um uh where he actually digs into the
actual papers that show how the
anomalies show up so
um uh i i think he may have talked about
that boot case
if i recall correctly yeah um so yeah
yeah i think the the general principle
here is
anomalies are not counter examples uh
you you don't you know
you should you should be curious about
these particular cases and
you know if you're really curious you
should look into them but you should
you know your default assumption should
be that this is an anomaly not a counter
example
yeah gaurav sharma
asks most questions don't or cannot
publish
failed or negative results only success
gets published
what steps can the scientific community
take to improve how we do science
and that that's a really good question
because especially if you want to take a
proper
perspective we're doing science
completely wrong because there's no
well actually there is there is a a
journal of failed experiments but
that's super rare for that stuff to get
published we publish the stuff that
works
yeah and uh they're absolutely right
both about the description and
that this is a problem um and
there has been some pushback recently
like very recently within the last 10
years
of a deliberate attempt to try and
change this there's several journals
that have been set up
one has been set specifically only to
publish replicated studies
uh so they won't publish new work they
only publish work that's been done
before oftentimes replicated studies
won't get published in other journals
um uh and yeah and then the other uh the
journal i can't handle the name of that
that's designed to publish research that
doesn't work
and hopefully if this kind of
sociological move
uh increases that that will be a
necessary counterbalance
to uh you know the desire to publish
only success um and again when you look
at sort of the sociological motivations
for why people start
scientific journals why they submit to
scientific journals
and why scientific journals continue to
publish that makes perfect sense right
they want to be the public story
the journal that publishes the next big
thing
right and we try this and it didn't work
isn't you know is probably not going to
be the next big thing
unless you're disproving a
well-established theory or something
like that
um uh that's not really gonna uh break a
whole lot of ground
so yeah we in in the interest of
intellectual honesty the scientific
community in particular
the publishing aspect of scientific
community really needs to
to broaden its understanding of what
counts as publishable work and to a
certain extent blogs and stuff like that
i think have helped a little bit with
this yeah
they have yeah yeah uh so because you
can get more of those ideas out there
even if you don't necessarily get the
full vetting that you're supposed to get
through
peer review and things like that um and
so at least the information is
accessible to other researchers and
scholars
one thing that that that nsf has been
doing lately is they've been funding
these huge
research um groups so they'll give
instead of instead of giving out you
know 10 000 or 100 000 here and there
they're giving out like 20 million
and forming these giant groups that just
last like 10 years or so and
then then they dissolve them and what's
cool about this
is scientists are often competing with
other researchers so if you're a origin
of life researcher you want to you want
to publish the the cool
thing when you're in a huge group of of
you know 100 other other investigators
you're no longer competitors you're all
going to meetings and you're you're
trying to coordinate your efforts
and all this conversation goes goes on
we're like oh
you're doing this oh we already tried
that and it failed
and you all sorts of of do-overs
are being avoided because we have these
larger groups that are
cooperating instead of competing so it's
interesting to see that
competing helps but also these large
cooperative groups
help in different ways yeah and it's
kind of cool to see that
and that comes back to the point i was
making earlier about balance right you
know there needs to be a balance between
open mindedness and closed mindedness a
balance between
trust uh and and skepticism and a
balance between cooperation and
competition
and the tricky thing is that there's no
sort of default
set point for what's the best balance it
always shifts and depends
on the particular field on the
particular question on the the political
landscape on the financial landscape all
these things will
will shift where that balance point
should be yeah
helen asks can we see your cat
she's been around yeah she's been
jumping up in my lap a little bit um i
tried to have the door closed but she
pushed it open
uh but at the moment she's not in the
room so okay and then uh let's see i
think i've got
um i'm just gonna do one last question
and then
uh sorry two there there are two more
questions here
and then we're gonna call it call it an
end andrew t
asks uh how can i combat
imposter syndrome in academia i i often
have doubts that i'm simply memorizing
the information rather than
understanding it deeply
yeah i know that's a really good
question um and it's it's it's outside
of my field of expertise i have no
particular expertise
on imposter syndrome uh there is
psychological research on this which i
don't
know i know it exists but i don't know
the details of it
um so i can't say anything authoritative
but i can't just speaking from my own
experiences and from the vicarious
experiences i've talked to
about others one thing which i find
helps
is the recognition that imposter
syndrome is very common
not everyone but lots of people even
very successful people suffer from
imposter syndrome
so you can sort of get a little bit of
perspective where you recognize well if
other people have these feelings too
even though they're incredibly
successful
and they've done very well for
themselves um then
you know maybe that says there's hope
for me
and if you want to be a little more
cynical about it uh it helps to find
people who are just really bad at what
they do
and succeed nonetheless i mean there's a
couple philosophers who i'm not going to
name because i don't want this to be
like
smack talk but there's a channel your
inner donald trump
um yeah but there's several philosophers
who i think are just really bad
but nonetheless have succeeded and so
and so that sort of goes to show
that there isn't a uh the the discipline
doesn't necessarily reward competence
and lots of people who suck at their
jobs succeed
that's true in academia as well as it's
true elsewhere
so it cuts both ways you can be really
good and still fail and you can be
really bad and still succeed
and that means that you know whatever
the pressure is making you feel like
you're like you're an imposter
very likely those social forces are not
responding to
whether or not you legitimately
understand it um right
uh so so don't be too hard on yourself
uh
trust the social mechanisms that are
designed to be gatekeeping you know
whether you're in a graduate program or
an undergraduate program or a lab or
whatever
if you've applied and if you've gotten
these the this funding
into this program uh uh trust that the
social
mechanisms are working um and if you
have applied and been rejected
then uh take comfort in the fact that
these these systems
aren't are far from perfect so you you
you you should
believe in yourself um that you
believe in the abilities of taking you
as far as they've taken you however far
that happens to be
and and andrew i would say i've talked
to a lot of researchers who
have basically the memorizing memorizing
information
is actually a lot of what you have to do
there's
we've discovered so many stinking things
so much research has been done
that you actually you have to just
memorize stuff without understanding it
to a degree once once you really get
into your specific field
then you can really digest what's happen
what's actually going on and really
really spend the time to actually
understand it inside and out but
i would say that memorization is really
important
uh you can't you can't have a
fundamental understanding of everything
so uh not to get off on a tangent here
but there actually is an interesting
philosophical
uh debate uh about the relationship
between memory and intelligence
uh you know socrates plato's socrates
famously said that writing was a mistake
because uh we don't memorize as much
anymore because we write it down
uh like sean connery says in indiana
jones on the last crusade i wrote it
down to my diary so i wouldn't
have to remember it um and uh you know a
lot of like
work in medieval uh uh uh theology and
philosophy
um the testimony how intelligent the
philosopher theologian was was about how
much they could remember because we
didn't have a printing press yet so a
lot you still had to remember
a lot of stuff and now of course we live
in the computer age where everything's
digital and you can google it and search
it and cross-reference it
so uh to a large extent you know uh uh
we we're getting
we're augmenting our own memories
through writing through the printing
press to the internet to computers
um and learning to to
balance epistemically how much you
personally have to have memorized at
your fingertips
and how much you just have to know where
to find that information if you need it
right um is is an evolving intellectual
and academic endeavor
yeah yeah yeah when you focus on your
field
you'll get you'll get to a level of
expertise where
uh you know in general what's known and
what's not known in your field
and where to look things up if you have
to
um yeah so yeah and another
standard piece of good advice this is
just for academics and people in general
don't be afraid to admit when you don't
know something you know
don't be afraid now even if it's in your
field even if it's something you should
know you think you should know
uh you know there are jerks out there
who will think that you are a fraud or a
charlatan if you don't have all this
some field memorized but thankfully my
experiences they tend to be few and far
between most people understand
that everyone has holes in their
knowledge base everyone has lapses of
memory
uh and that's that's human and that's
acceptable so we don't need to be
embarrassed about that
i mean i forgot huxley's name i had to
google it a second ago right you know
there's a part of me that kicks myself
for not remembering huxley's name
but again that's human it's acceptable
um i i we got a i got a super chat um
carmel crank ass crunk asks uh
can you reach out to inspiring
philosophy to have a discussion about
the origin of life and evolution
uh that'd be a good idea inspiring
philosophy
he is a christian who takes evolution
seriously
and origin of life science seriously so
that that would be
if i'm remembering right i think that's
who inspiring philosophy is
uh that would be an interesting
conversation to have him on
um let me see there was there was one
more question uh
oh gosh there's a couple of good
questions but
um this was this was the last one that i
said
we were gonna respond to the chat is
preoccupied the chat
here on on this on this video is
preoccupied and considering how
subjective experience
poses a counter-argument to objective
empiricism
can you ask to what extent does
philosophy of science accept this
uh uh i have a a bit of a pe
and a theory here um
that the objective subject to
distinction is at best confusing and at
worst meaningless
okay um uh somewhat similar to our
earlier conversation but natural versus
supernatural yeah uh
i think when you when you push on it
philosophically and ask people to
to unpack it you either end up defining
objective in terms of subjective or
subjective in terms of objective
uh and you just end up being in a
lose-lose situation it depends entirely
on which one you start with which one
you define
the other in terms of um and you're
going to run into a whole host of
different philosophical problems
depending on whether you go from one to
the other if the other to the one
and i think the best way to resolve
these problems is to simply reject the
distinction entirely
but that's my way of thinking that's
certainly not a popular or a common way
of thinking
so using objective and subjective in the
way i think they're commonly used
i think it's fair to say that that
serious philosophers of science
recognize that you can never get
entirely away from subjectivity because
it's subjects that are doing the science
so usually i think what they say the
best you can hope for is not so much
objectivity as something called
inter-subjectivity where
where the different subjective
perspectives all kind of triangulate to
a single uh
general conclusion and as long as the
the multiple different perspectives end
up being different paths of the same
mountain
uh then it doesn't really matter if you
want if we can call it objective as such
what matters is that we have a high
degree of inter-subjective reliability
and that's what science does best is it
is it incentivizes lots of different
people to find different pathways
and then we can see whether or not those
pathways all lead to the same point or
not
great um we're getting a bunch of
questions now but um let me just rattle
these off here really quick
uh eric's eric c asks do you think the
idea of religion was evolutionary
evolutionarily necessary or useful at
least at some point in time
i've got a whole video on this several
videos on this
uh my conclusion is that yes uh
religion is super important for
solidarity and so on and
was especially important in the past um
but i think
uh all sorts of different cultural
stories could play that role
um you're nodding your head exactly yeah
yeah yeah i agree
uh it plays an important role socially
human beings need to cooperate
and work together um both in our
ancestral past and
in our modern day and we need uh
stories to and to rally around to to get
us to coordinate and cooperate
sometimes those stories are political
sometimes they're ideological sometimes
they're
religious sometimes they're scientific
you know they
the these sort of stories can take all
sorts of forms
there's nothing that needs to be
necessarily religious about it but
religions are good because they come
you know sort of cheap on the tech tree
as it were they're they're
they are in the primitive world they're
easy to create and easy to found
um and because people are desperate for
stories they're desperate for meaning
um uh it's pretty easy for religions to
succeed at least locally
um and they can get your tribe to come
together and work together because the
gods need you to do this to hunt and so
forth
and that's how the human race survived
so yeah
and my brother asks why does nutrition
science change so much so fast
yeah um that's a very good question and
it's one you know uh
uh i get into oftentimes with friends
you know i i'm
i'm a vegan and so i'm particularly
interested in the nutrition research
around veganism versus
non-vegan diets yeah uh i think your
brother's absolutely right
it's so it's it's a mess um you know
seemingly reputable studies will be
published uh that seems to suggest one
thing and then five years later a whole
host of
studies will seem to suggest the other
um and so
the question is to why i think there's
two basic answers one is because it's
incredibly complicated there's just
so many moving parts it's really hard to
isolate anything in nutrition you've got
genetics
you have the actual diets you have the
cultural factors you have exercise
you know there's just so many other
things that you can't control for
and so the way that you normally try to
do that is with large studies right and
you hope that those differences will
wash out
but then when you get to that you get to
the other major problem then that's
ethical
constraints you know if you had no
ethical compunctions at all
you could perform all kinds of very
effective nutrition research
experiments uh that would involve
treating people in really unethical ways
um but because we as as scientific
community as human beings in general
decide that uh
that uh it's more important to obey the
ethical rules than it is to to get to
the bottom of these nutrition science
research
this nutritionist research we tend to
prioritize the ethics
over figuring out what actually works in
nutrition so who knows
hopefully at some point in the future
nutrition science will
we'll we'll start nailing things down
and do a lot better but for now yeah
it seems like it's a mess yeah mike
there there's a funny thing um
we understand exactly how to feed a
chicken
so that it costs almost nothing and
makes them grow extremely fast
and we're able to figure that out
through really nasty experiments
on chickens we can't do that with people
um
so whatever whatever your goal is
whether it be longevity or
muscle building like we just haven't
been able to do those
those really highly controlled
experiments on humans because they're
such nasty experiments to do
and and that with mixed with marketing
and people who
want to lose weight but don't want to do
exercise and like there's just
so many competing competing motives
and competing like
what do you want out of nutrition do you
want to eat in a way that's good for the
environment
good for other animals which you know
veganism
is is seems to be the way to go for
those two things but
arguably i mean maybe maybe um
harvesting wheat kills lots of mice
whereas harvesting
a cow kills one cow but then you also
have to
kill mice in the slaughterhouse rats in
the slaughterhouse i mean there's
there's
so it gets really complicated um
but yeah there's there's many moving
parts in the ethics just like there's
many moving parts in the actual
biomechanics
so yeah the um
and then the last little we're gonna
edit here but this is a really good
this is probably the perfect way to to
end this what books do you recommend
people read on the philosophy of science
for those of us who are not in the field
and let me just say before you answer
that i highly recommend
you go listen to um
garrett's youtube channel so that's
sisyphus redeemed
go check that out that is it's
absolutely amazing
he he really he really goes over and
there's tons of content on there are you
still actively producing
yeah actually i've i've recorded a
couple of uh another
uh three short lectures for the series
but i've been waiting to post them
um because recent events make it seem
like it's not really an appropriate time
for me to be uploading
uh uh that kind of stuff to my channel i
sort of feel like i i want to be taking
a step back and letting
uh uh it just seems the tone of the
nation right now seems to be focused on
other things
yeah but once presumably once that
settles down uh i'll release the the
most recent ones i recorded so yeah
um but thank you thank you thank you for
the plug and thank you for the
compliment um
but to to answer the question directly i
mean again the book that i use that
series for
it's this is the textbook that i use for
my philosophy science class theory in
reality by peter godfrey smith
um uh it covers not the exact same
ground but a lot of the same ground that
i cover in that lecture series
so i like that book a lot thomas kuhn
structure scientific
structure scientific revolutions i think
is indispensable for anyone who really
wants to understand 20th century
philosophy of science
uh it is arguably the most important
book in 20th century philosophy of
science
um and then uh also sort of beyond that
i think one of the things which is
interesting and i think this is the
direction a lot of philosophy of science
is taking nowadays
is it's it's started to to specialize
more there's less work being done in
generic philosophy of science and more
work being done in specific subfields
like philosophy of physics or philosophy
of biology
um and so if you have a interest in a
particular field
um then there's lots of good work being
done
you know in the philosophy of that field
i'm in the middle of a book right now
um uh called lost in math uh by
sabine hof i think her name is
um and she's a theoretical physicist and
she's talking about the relationship
between beauty
uh and and and particle physics uh and
so she's a physicist not a philosopher
but it's a really philosophically very
rich book
um and so i'll plug that one too just
because i'm in the middle of it right
now i'm really enjoying it so if you
like if you like
theoretical physics check out lost in
math cool
great well thank you for coming on that
this
seriously was it's kind of like uh like
you know i've watched all your stuff
not all of your stuff but i've watched a
lot of your stuff and it's just so cool
to meet someone
that i've been following for a while and
uh it's it's great to have you on i mean
this was really a cold call i just sent
you i think
steve mcrae connected me with you
actually right yeah um yeah
and then just look i mean let me put
this out here in this regard i'm a cheap
date in that regard i'm happy to talk to
anyone who wants to talk about this
stuff so if anyone else out there has a
podcast or a youtube channel and you
want to have me on have a conversation
shoot shoot me a a a message on on my
twitter you know at
sisyphus redeemed um uh and uh we'll set
something up
awesome oh okay actually i i lied i do
have one more question
and that is in the philosophy world
how do you how do you make a name for
yourself because it seems like
to as an outsider looking in it seems it
seems kind of random as to who gets
you know like popper became everybody
for some reason knows popper but no one
knows lockatosh
like how on earth does this work
yeah i'm somewhat disillusioned with the
discipline in that regard um
one of the the projects i've been
working on i'm going to turn this into a
paper at some point but the problem is
it requires a very uh detailed survey of
the literature which i haven't had time
for
i have a pet theory which suggests that
papers that use thought experiments are
more likely to be published
and more likely to be uh to be reprinted
and to be remembered
and to have bigger impact factors than
papers that don't use thought
experiments and philosophy
um i'm going to use a thought experiment
in your paper
right there's a self-interesting if my
theory is right i i would serve my own
self-interest to use a thought
experiment
um but you know that requires a lot of
bibliographic
uh research which i is not something i
have expertise in to to actually prove
that i dare
to even test that idea but if it's
correct
then it what it suggests is that
philosophers are attracted to
to shiny things right um uh and and
there can be lots of great work out
there which gets ignored because it
doesn't have the fun
memorable poppy you know bloggable
little thought experiments that's gonna
stick in people's minds so yeah i i
think that's
you know what makes people succeed in
philosophy is there's a lot of things
and fairly
little of it has to do with overall
intellectual quality obviously you have
to meet certain minimal standards
but there's nepotism in the field you
know there's there's there's a lot of
playing favorites it's still an old boys
club there's a lot of sexism
and and and a lot of ingrained racial
bias in a lot of ways
um and cultural biases and stuff like
that all of those things can either way
in your favor or against you depending
on whether you're lucky and whether or
not you're mercenary um
so yeah i i i i it's sad to say that uh
uh you know you would imagine that
philosophers would be only care about
the quality of ideas
but that's you know we're only human uh
and we get distracted by other things
too we have emotions and
we like stories so right one of the
things that i really appreciate
appreciate about your work versus other
people who who claim to be philosophers
is
uh well a lot of internet philosophers
that i meet
but a lot of people don't read anyone
else's work and they just have their own
ideas and they're trying to get it out
there but it seems like you have spent
career studying what other people are
doing and reporting on that in a way
that the public can really understand
which is
why i love your channel have you are you
aiming to make any big contributions
yourself and and try and get those out
there because because what i've seen of
your work so far is summarizing what
other people have done
yeah i mean in all fields of academia
there's
synthesizers and there's generators
right um and and yeah i think it's very
definitely my youtube stuff
uh is more synthesis than generation um
i do have my own original research and
stuff like that and i like it well
enough
um but general broadly speaking kind of
like i was suggesting earlier i'm not
particularly interested
in making a huge impact i don't want to
give a damn about credit
i got into this because i want to
understand things um
and i'm not so arrogant as to think that
my ideas in and of themselves are going
to be the ones that transform the world
or ultimately unlock the keys to the
universe
um you know so if other people have
great ideas
um and and i can connect those great
ideas to other people's ideas and help
other people see the greatness in these
ideas and
it can give them something then then
that's that's fine by me i have
i have no i don't say no i have very
little in the way of ego
invested in it and i don't particularly
particularly care
for you know being high profile or
something like that or getting a job at
a
you know r1 research institution program
or or leading a think tank or
a philosophy lab or anything like that
you know i yeah there's there's there's
upsides to all of that don't get me
wrong i'm not saying i'm not interested
in that or that i don't care about it
um but yeah i'm not i'm i'm not in this
for ego gratification i'm not in this to
to to leave a legacy or to start a
school of thought
or anything like that i'm in it because
for selfish reasons because i want to
understand the stuff
and you i think you do a lot more by
reading the refined work of other people
than you do just by sitting on your own
and just generating your own ideas you
know there should be some of that but
yeah well i i really appreciate your
work it's been really helpful for me
so there is a legacy you're leaving at
least at least in my mind so
i i appreciate that and thank you so
much for coming on here this was great
so yeah thank you for having me dr
garrett miriam everyone
and with that we will end the stream so
long for now stay curious